I got my guy George Kittle
huge fan of this guy
um you know I've been uh knowing George
for a little bit man and um you know we
got a little bit of history on the
football field George gave me my very
first Pancake in the league that I've
ever experienced in my life and that
that thought was on my mind so much that
when I got back to LA like I got on
Instagram and I like DM these guys it
was I dm'd you and juice it was probably
like it's probably like four o'clock in
the morning I woke up to it I was like
well I'm laying in the bed I got like
man I gotta hit these guys when I
started to see him I had I started to
see if I had the cell phone like I ain't
got I'm going I'm I'm like I got a damn
new job I'm like man you got me I forgot
what I said I said man you got me but
you had your bodyguard with you and you
was like man you know I always keep my
god with me man but you know it's that's
just part of it man you know if you play
the game long enough like [__] happens
yeah [__] happens bro and you know that
was a good play I Remember at the very
end I was trying to like I was trying to
like wiggle out and like follow my sign
and you had to grip and I was like oh I
had an inside hand really nice I was
like oh [__] it's about to happen and it
did and I tried to I tried to roll up
real fast nobody saw it and then when I
got back you got up real fast I got up
real fast like as fast I could and when
I got back in the locker room you check
your phone like it is [__] viral but
that's just part of it man George Kittle
Hall of Fame tight end man I appreciate
you being on the show
um you know George is here with a
Gatorade fast twitch it is a new energy
drink from Gatorade it is um
I have tried it I have tried at the
facility It's Made In in uh consultation
with the NFL and design for athletes
with 200 milligrams of caffeine no sugar
electrolytes zero sugar and it's
available Nationwide and I saw that
commercial too first it was you Diggs
and it was somebody else on there too
yeah I can't remember but I know me and
Diggs shot like back-to-back days
commercial was fun it was really cool
experience now that was like the biggest
production I've ever done but I don't
know it's uh I'm a big I think I think
everybody does caffeine before football
games you need a little bit of a
pick-me-up and then
the fast switch came out this year and I
I started using it so I didn't use it
until like week nine or ten and then I
had four games with two touchdowns I was
like ah key to success
you're a high energy guy so like this
right you drink it before practice was
just games too practicing games does it
like boost yo because sometimes you get
that caffeine and then like it just it
gets you jittery but doesn't know
Jitters does it change like your your
mood because I feel like some energy
drinks the best energy drinks that I
take they like pick you up they change
it like your mood like if you you know
you want to work out but if you feeling
a little bit down you drink that you're
ready to go that's how I feel that's
hard yeah and then you don't have any of
the jittery feeling like I drink like
half of it 75 of it and then uh like
I'll do the warmth and I'll drink the
rest of it and then by the time I'm
through my warm-up and I'm wired and
ready to roll oh that's cool man it's
good stuff that's cool man I saw you
guys at the Pro Bowl last week you know
um I saw you guys uh yeah with moose
yeah with moose in the club yo he's a
huge 49ers fan it was you Christian
McCaffrey
um
it was uh juice juice was there wait
which one I went out a couple times I
just saw one I think y'all went with
moose every single time one yeah yeah I
think so I think it was the last day I
saw like I saw like your post on on the
last day oh yeah yeah we had we had a
wonderful group of guys there yeah Joey
burrow made it in with Bosa those two
are boys so yeah he was fresh too Joey
he had the glasses on with the I forgot
what outfit it had yeah Joey he's a
freshman guy just a cool guy man it is
man he's the future in the NFL man he's
swaggy on and off the football field so
how was how was Las Vegas with that Pro
Bowl like it was fun it's still fun yeah
they did a great job this year uh they
put us right on the Strip we're like our
hotel we were in didn't have uh you know
Casino in it but you're three minutes
away from the Aria and stuff like that
so it was easy access guys uh enjoyed it
rooms were wonderful the Pro Bowl
experience was fun too I mean like seven
on seven you could kind of tell by the
the third game when uh because like the
winner of that game got an extra 40K
bonus so oh yeah so guys we started
trying really hard it was funny you
could see the effort going in out there
in the third game and was pretty fun it
was it was a good time that's cool man
um you know let's take a moment to
celebrate Brock Purdy and everything
that he accomplished this season
um is he the future of the 49ers I know
you got Jimmy G yeah they got treylands
coming back
is he is he the future of 49er I don't
know what's going on with Jimmy he's a
free agent so whatever happens there
happens uh Trey Lance is still there and
you know Trey unfortunately has not
really gotten a fair shot of being an
NFL quarterback yet you got a full reign
game Monsoon versus the Bears and they
got hurt in the second game so you know
Trey still got plenty of talent he just
needs to get out there and play and then
you but you can't you can't talk about
what Brock pretty has like what he did
like he's fantastic he our offense was
operating at the highest it's probably
been and you know since 2019 so I mean
in my opinion it's Brock's job lose yeah
but I mean you there will be competition
because Brock's gonna be out till you
know training camp with his surgery so
it's going to be interesting but when
you find a guy like that that can
seamlessly jump in I mean I think it's
his job to lose for sure you know I like
to you know um as I as I um pass career
as I pass years you know I'm here in the
National Football League I started to
think about life after football now that
I'm ready to like yeah for sure because
I want to play Forever like why not but
obviously you have to have like you have
to start that thought process Exit Plan
you know and for me I want to still be
attached to football right for sure and
um you know I want to be a GM like that
is like over time you know seeing um
John Elway seeing Leslie seeing John
lunch seeing John Lynch that like that's
my God that's that I was going to get to
John unless that's my guy he played
defense he went to he went to TV for a
little bit and then he uh he went to the
49ers and he was actually in the room
when I did my combine he was in the room
with John Elway that's sick and he was
shadowing John Elway then a couple of
years later he got the job for the 49ers
oh that's sick how is how is John Legend
the second question that is how is uh
Kyle Shanahan as well oh uh John is
fantastic you could tell how much he
loves the players he's uh he's straight
up with you he's honest with you from
everyone I have fortunately never had
really an experience with him that was
uh hey you're he never called me his
opposite release me or stuff like that
so positive
um positive interaction with him but
he's such a great vibe in the facility
especially like he's a walking Hall of
Famer and he talks every everybody with
a ton of respect he knows everybody he
spends time asking about your family so
like he makes you feel very wanted and
like he wants you to be there so I
really appreciate that about John and
whenever you get one of his uh like he
doesn't talk to the team too often but
like when we get to the playoffs he like
shows some like tape sometimes like uh
when the Buccaneers went into Philly and
one like back in 2002 yeah and then they
went on the ones who were like seeing
him talk about stuff like that it's
pretty inspiring I mean John Lynch Hall
of Famer is pretty sick sure Shanahan uh
he's a riot man I mean his offensive
schemes are fantastic he's super smart
uh but at the end of the day and he
likes to hang out with the guys and he
he just likes to get to know you
um but he's got a lot of energy and he
likes to have a fun time for sure man um
you know I saw you guys y'all started
the tight end University which is super
cool I started the password Summit it
was just a it was just a way for me to
give back to the game that is given so
much to me you know and I wanted to
create like this this Pro Bowl type of
feel because everybody's not gonna make
the Pro Bowl no but when I was at the
Pro Bowl like being around like TJ Wad
and you know being around well like a
unique in dogway and all these other
rushers and really picking their mind
and being on the same team for a week it
kind of It kind of it wanted me to it
put me in a position to really share
that experience with other guys that
won't make the Pro Bowl so I started the
password Summit what was the um what was
the you know the intention behind Titan
you uh well first I saw your password
Summit and then I saw the o-line
masterminds they did that I'm good
friends with Lane Johnson uh my dad
coached him at Oklahoma
um but really tired of you like I work I
like to work out with other NFL athletes
I like to compete with them I like to
not really compare myself to them but
just like see what other guys in the
league are doing and so I was I trained
like five to ten NFL tight ends
um Greg Olsen retired and I was like hey
Greg you want to come down here and like
you know teach some guys some stuff and
he was like why don't we invite some
more people and then we thought we're
gonna invite 20 people next thing we
knew the first time we had 49 people
yeah flooded we didn't have enough space
for people and then the next year we had
85 tight ends we did the whole thing at
Vanderbilt University it was fantastic
the whole intent behind it is I want
guys to feel comfortable being able to
talk to other Titans around the NFL I
won a rookie from the Giants to be able
to go up to Travis Kelsey ask him about
something send them a text like hey like
what are your thoughts on this and it's
really fun because the interactions you
have at tight ends now in season like I
talked to like 15 to 20 guys throughout
the season consistently that's really
fun for me where it's like hey you guys
played these guys last week what do you
like what are your thoughts on this
defensive end like how did he play you
guys and that's stuff I really enjoy and
really just building that Brotherhood
and that friendship because there's a
lot of knowledge out there and not every
coach is really good at their job but
there's some really fantastic football
players that have figured it out on
their own and so they might give you a
tip that might help you in your career
and become a better player I will say
this too Von my dad was the opposite
tackles coach at Oklahoma when you
played at Texas A M and he did say that
you're the greatest defensive he's ever
seen on tape before like he he always
tell me about you when you're in college
like this guy's gonna be one of the best
football players ever in the NFL and
goodness gracious you're still pretty
good aren't you yeah that's cool man you
give uh your dad my uh I appreciate your
love man I appreciate you man I
appreciate you guys man that's love man
for sure man
um you know I I I I like I talk to the
defensive ends throughout the season too
I feel like you know the NFL like when
they so they come out with the top 100
and they had this guy in one and two and
you know we you have to have pride to be
successful in a National Football League
yeah but when we see this it's just this
this sense of Pride like man Audi he's
number three I'm really supposed to be
number three and I started the pastor
Summit to kind of like tear that down
like you know life is it's right
football is already hard enough like
hard we don't need to be competing
against each other like we're not even
on the field at the same time if I can't
if and I feel so comfortable in my game
that I can give you the whole thing and
I'm not feeling like oh like I don't
want to tell them this because he he
might do it better than me like I'm a
bro I'm an open book I'm so comfortable
with my game
um the football is giving me it's it's
done so much for me man like you said
this is how I pay it forward and you
know I started to pass for a summit and
I saw you guys do tight end University
and you know off really the wide
receivers and cornerbacks need to do it
they need to do it bro but to get these
wide receivers to link up with other
wide receivers and then go to corner
like have cornerbacks there too and you
know it might be it might be a little
bit toxic but you know they they really
need to do it man because they can do so
much they can do so much man they can do
so much man um no I serious saying too
because like there is there is a
competitive Advantage like everyone's
computer for the first team All Pro the
pro bowls and stuff like that but like
at the end of the day we're all NFL
athletes like everybody's gonna have a
shot to get there and just based on your
play you get all stuff like that but
like you don't need to compete with guys
that you don't even share the field with
like like I have a Competitive Edge with
you like we we compete like Head to Head
physically but like me and Travis don't
compete really like he gets throwing the
football
like everybody else against each other
in comparison Steve of Joy isn't it
that's crazy man it's crazy but I mean
like my goal is like I want to give
everyone this information so then they
go out there they have a fantastic year
and then they raise the bar in the South
like on the contract level and I hope
like I want Kaidens to get I mean like
hey man I think we're at 15 million
right now I don't know why Travis
Kelsey's even getting paid 25 million
kills getting 30. yeah receivers getting
30 like he but he's he's worth that he
has that type of impact on the game both
of you guys do yeah and most of you guys
do so I'm just we're trying to like I
want everyone to have these great ears
and then that keeps going up tight ends
get paid and I just feel like the time
position is just going to continue to
evolve because they're just all of us
are so different too it's kind of like
defense like you have guys that are six
foot you have Nick both you can do it
all you have giant people who can just
like Jared Allen who can just pancake
yeah little guys that can go yeah yeah
you got the speed like when you and then
it's just cool like there's just so many
different techniques that might work for
you or they might not just based on your
body hey man hey George man you know I
appreciate you man I'm a huge you know
fan of you man you know um the glasses
the uh what What's the uh what's the
glasses you got a glasses deal there's
any there's any deal man I'm a huge fan
of that man you know I got Vons Vision I
do you know I get back contacts like the
surgery glasses the kids in need man and
I just I've been a huge fan of you man
from from day one man and I appreciate
you being on the show if it's if it's
anything that you ever need for me man
you know I'm just a text a DM you know a
smoke signal away man whatever you need
man you know I got you bro for sure for
sure man sir I'm a huge fan of you man
huge fan of your game man I know you're
a great guy in the locker room man just
by putting my antennas out and you just
when you've been in league so long you
just you just know man and you know
you're a great dude man and if you ever
need me man you know I got you bro
appreciate that appreciate it yes sir